[Musique]
bonjour nouveau débat sur tb 68 dans le
cas de ce second tour des élections
municipales aujourd'hui consacré à la
ville de rambouillet trois listes seront
présentes pour ce second tour programmé
le 28 juin prochain à rambouillet en
commun porté par des bijoutiers
génération rambouillet porté par gilles
hashemite rambouillet ensemble vers
l'avenir porté par véronique matillon
les trois têtes de liste sont avec nous
via écran interposé pour débattre un
contexte sanitaire oblige
bonjour à vous trois alors nous avons
tout d'abord commencé par un résumé a du
1er tour des municipales le 15 mars
dernier à rambouillet sur tous les
enjeux dans la commune regardez ce
reportage
après le premier tour des élections
municipales 2020 à rambouillet en mars
dernier véronique matillon candidat
divers droite est en première position
la candidate soutenue par le maire
sortant marc robert devance david jutier
de la liste écologiste à rambouillet en
commun en troisième position on retrouve
gilles schmitt candidats la république
en marche les rangs politain se sont peu
mobilisés sur cette élection la
participation était seulement de 41,26 %
différents enjeux se dégage de ces
élections municipales la commune de 26
mille habitants à une double identité
urbaine et rurale situant clairière de
la forêt de rambouillet la ville
appartient pour sa partie non urbaines
au parc national régional de la haute
vallée de chevreuse 77% des espaces
rural à préserver notamment des moyens
de déplacement à repenser la ville
bénéficie également d'un patrimoine
riche avec le château qui date du 15ème
siècle ou encore la bergerie nationale
de structure qui accueille plusieurs
milliers de visiteurs chaque année la
visibilité de ces sites et à développer
autre enjeu nées de la crise sanitaire
liée aux chorales à virus la
conservation des commerces en
centre-ville
plusieurs petits commerces pourraient se
retrouver en difficulté dans les
prochaines années
avant cet épisode le taux d'occupation
des surfaces commerciales et 2 93% les
boutiques vides sont trois fois moins
nombreuses que dans le reste de la
france
enfin la santé sera également un enjeu
sur la commune la ville bénéficie
notamment d'un centre hospitalier la
ville n'est pas encore considérée comme
un désert médical selon les chiffres de
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé
une trentaine de médecins sont présents
sur la ville mais ce chiffre est en
baisse de 20% sur dix ans
et la moitié de ses médecins à plus de
55 ans au cours de ces débats de 40
minutes ça suive également sur radio
sensations je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole sera chronométrée afin
d'assurer au mieux l'égalité entre
chaque cas nous afficherons
régulièrement le temps de parole des
trois candidats à l'écran comme
d'habitude nous débutons ce premier tour
de table avec cette question pourquoi
les électeurs doivent voter pour vous
sur ce second tour
vous avez environ deux minutes nous
débutons avec vous david jutier nous
prônons l'ordre établi sur les listes de
la préfecture et ce sera l'ordre inverse
pour vos conclusions tout à l'heure
alors david jutier vous êtes arrivé en
deuxième position avec 27 % des
suffrages avec votre liste soutenue par
europe ecologie les verts par génération
le parti animalistes et génération
écologie
vous êtes élue d'opposition au conseil
municipal depuis à 2014 pourquoi les
électeurs doivent voter pour vous sur ce
second tour bonjour à toutes et à tous
merci ce débat les coûts d'espoir que
les résultats du premier tour ont montré
une réelle envie de changement à
rambouillet en tout cas de la part de
celles et ceux qui se sont déplacés moi
le principal enseignement que je tire de
ce premier tour c'est cela c'est une
majorité sortante qui à nouveau
n'atteint que 44% des suffrages donc
loin de là loin de la majorité absolue
donc une majorité de rambo litanie de
rang boletin souhaitent un changement
souhaite faire évoluer leur ville et je
pense que leurs suffrages doit se porter
sur nous parce que on a montré qu'on
avait un vrai projet pour modifier la
manière dont rambouillet et gérer et
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes les mieux
placés pour porter ce projet est incarné
un changement pour rambouillet un projet
global qui se décline au niveau global
et qui se saisit des grands enjeux de
notre époque j schmitt vous êtes
également élu au conseil municipal vous
avez quitté la majorité il ya un peu
plus d'un an vous avez été investi par
la république en marche soutenue
également par le modem et agir vous êtes
le suppléant de la députée de la 10e
circonscription robert g vous avez
réalisé à 22% des suffrages au premier
tour pourquoi les électeurs doivent
t'ils vaud
et pour vous j'invite les électeurs de
voter pour nous pour une narration si
nous avons un dossier qui est ambitieux
nous avons un projet ambitieux solidaire
qui a pris en compte un certain nombre
de thématiques la transition écologique
et la santé et qui est finançable
et c'est un aussi un projet qui ne se
verra pas augmenté par des impôts locaux
je souhaite que nous venons de vivre
depuis un certain nombre d'années le
dernier vente a été dans un contexte
complètement inédit je ne cache pas
qu'on attend d'elle à ostie à je veux
dire à un autre un niveau de
participation plus élevée donc
aujourd'hui la marge de manoeuvre est
encore été grande et très grande
je crois que onze mille oeufs
rambolitains ne se sont pas déplacés
pour voter sur les 7 me qui se sont
exprimés au premier tour donc il ya tout
lieu de à la fois des d'espérer et tout
lieu de convaincre que notre liste ne
sera pas dans la rupture as rajon et
dans la dans un dans une évolution de la
commune c'est à dire que on tient compte
bien sûr de ce qui a été fait il ya des
choses qui doivent être dès qu'ils
doivent changer certaines doivent
évoluer et doit être changée avec bien
sûr un peu plus de participation
démocratique locale avec une autre
application en termes d'eau trigger en
termes de gestion
il ya un autre regard sur les sur les
déplacements de la ville sur des
mobilités voilà donc c'est surtout pas
la révolution pour certains aspects
c'est une évolution ou d'autres ce sera
un changement effectif
enfin véronique matignon sur le plan
politique vous êtes soutenus par le
maire sortant de la commune marc robert
vous êtes adjointe au maire en charge
des affaires scolaires et familiales
vous êtes première après ce premier tour
avec 43 % des suffrages
véronique matillon pourquoi les
électeurs doivent voter pour vous sur ce
second tour alors tout d'abord je vous
remercie d'avoir organisé ce débat
en effet je suis arrivé en tête avec
près de 44% des voix
monsieur jutier effectivement dit que ça
n'est pas la majorité mais il est forcé
de constater tout de même que les
rambolitains se sont largement exprimés
en ma faveur je suis en effet de
l'équipe sortante je suis soutenue par
le maire actuel dont je fais partie des
kits je suis je pense
celle qui s'est présenté sans aucune
étiquette politique je suis convaincu
que ça aussi ça a compté dans le vote
des rambolitains je suis là avec une
ambition et une seule celle de la ville
de rambouillet je les dis qu'on dans
toute cette campagne je suis connue à
travers les écoles puisque je suis
adjointe aux écoles mais fait
précédemment je me suis occupé de la
petite enfance et c'est vrai que c'est
un domaine où on est proche des
rambolitains notre projet est basé sur
le bien vivre ensemble sur l'humain sur
la solidarité et à la sortie de cette
crise sanitaire
force est de constater que c'est d'abord
de cela que les citoyens ont besoin
donc voilà je pense que notre liste
représente à la fois l'expérience et le
renouvellement parce que j'ai renouvelé
en grande partie des qui mais
l'expérience et tous les projets que
nous présentons sont présentés avec un
budget qui permet leur réalisation
alors nous avons terminé ce premier tour
de table nous allons regarder les
chronos david jutier vous en êtes à une
minute exactement véronique mathieu une
minute 37 g schmitt une minute trente et
une alors nous allons passer aux
thématiques de ce débat nous allons
commencer par une thématique sur les
commerces de proximité avec la crise
sanitaire que nous avons connue avec le
coguic 19 plusieurs petits commerces
risque de se retrouver en difficulté
dans les prochains mois ou dans les
prochaines années dans la commune avant
cet épisode le taux d'occupation des
surfaces commerciales été de 93% les
boutiques vides sont trois fois moins
nombreuses que dans le reste de la
france
à rambouillet quelles sont vos
propositions pour le centre ville et son
attractivité nous allons commencer par
vous david jutier vous êtes en retard
pour l'instant oui merci alors écoutez
je crois qu'effectivement la crise
coville a placé certains commerces en
grande difficulté qu'il faut absolument
leur apporter des réponses concrètes
immédiates il ya des fonds régionaux qui
ont été créés pour cela la commération à
abonder ce fonds très récemment
c'est une excellente chose il faut pas
que les commerçants hésitent à faire
appel à ces dispositifs qu'il faut
pérenniser la ville doit être
accompagnée évidemment et moi mais ma
préoccupation pour le commerce de
proximité le commerce de centre ville ce
sont des solutions de plus long terme
parce que les difficultés qu'ils
connaissaient avant le coc vides n'ont
pas disparu et on les connaît ses
difficultés c'est la concurrence de des
zones commerciales de périphérie c'est
bien pour ça que je me suis battu bec et
ongles et que j'ai obtenu gain de cause
pour peu un village de la voiture ne
s'implante pas entérite péri sur les
terres agricoles ondes de bel air à la
fois c'était une ineptie à la fois
écologique et économique dont il faut
absolument arrêter cette concurrence
énorme des zones commerciales
périphériques qui tue le commerce à
petit feu la deuxième bonne cause de
difficultés du commerce de centre-ville
sait les difficultés à se rendre en
centre ville
la difficulté qu'on a déplacé à y
déambuler donc nous avons un plan de
circulation qui doit permettre de
repartager l'ensemble de l'espace urbain
entre la voiture bien entendu les
piétons évidemment et les cyclistes bien
sûr aussi plus tous les autres rois de
alternatif de déplacement et de manière
sécurisée ça c'est extrêmement important
nous avons un plan de déplacement qui
est le pied cohérent qui devrait
permettre d circulation apaisée et
agréable dans la ville et puis la
troisième difficulté à laquelle sont
confrontés les commerces et l'animation
du centre-ville
en général c'est le manque de diversité
des enseignes en centre ville et dans
les rues alentour
et pour cela la solution c'est un faux
de préemption des commerçants qui se
libère par la ville de manière à ce
qu'elles puissent les réattribuer par
l'intermédiaire d'une commission qui
comprendra bien sûr les commerçants des
débuts
des citoyens les associations de manière
à ce qu'elle les réattribuer les
revendre ou simplement à des enseignes
qui assure une diversité une animation
dans le la ville on avait proposé la
création de sophie en particulier
lorsque la maroquinerie du centre-ville
a été racheté par des pompes funèbres
skill que tu n'aimes pas mal déçu les
commerçants du centre-ville à l'époque
malheureusement ni gilles schmidt dans
la majorité
à l'époque ni à véronique à matignon
n'avait apporté croit crédit à cette
idée est bien avec dans notre programme
et nous la mettrons le 23 nov
véronique mathieu on voulait répondre
alors oui le commerce de proximité peut
être en difficulté et éventuellement la
crise qu vide a rendu pour certains
commerçants les choses difficiles
nous voyons aussi parce que je les
rencontre depuis la sortie du
confinement qu'ils ont su mettre des
stratégies en classe qu'ils vont
poursuivre avec des livraisons ils sont
été très actif il faut le reconnaître
ces commerçants au des capacités à
s'adapter à des situations extrêmement
compliqué comme celle du co ville et le
commerce de proximité en centre ville
évidemment nous aussi nous pensons à la
façon dont les personnes peuvent
déambuler et il y a dans nos projets des
travaux que nous ferons avec les
commerçants et avec les habitants du
centre ville parce que lorsqu'on parle
du piétonnisation même partiel il faut
penser également aux riverains
évidemment avec toute la restructuration
autour du quartier gare qui permettra
aux rambolitains et aux personnes
extérieures parce que le commerce est
encore une fois ce n'est pas seulement
les rambolitains de pouvoir leur
permettre un accès plus facile au centre
ville mais le commerce de proximité
c'est aussi le commerce qui se situe
dans les quartiers et nous devons
absolument faire en sorte que deux des
commerçants des petites boutiques du
commerce de proximité arrive dans les
quartiers j'étais tout à l'heure dans le
quartier de grosses et et il y a à une
petite épicerie qui est présente et il
nous a dit à quel point elle avait eu
beaucoup de clients durant cette crise
coville il est important que nous
développions non seulement les commerces
en centre-ville mais aussi les commerces
dans les quartiers parce que la
proximité c'est aussi dans les quartiers
jésuite
vous avez une les 31 pour l'instant de
teint parole
c'est assez tabou mais tout à fait alors
puisque vite qui a frappé durement le
monde est entre autres nous sommes des
commerçants le commerce de drogue seront
effectivement on a retrouvé de
l'activité du compte ait de l'humour est
en cela que ça a été on a trouvé aussi
tous la nécessité la fois du smi ce mois
ci du contact ça c'est sur l'aspect
social en date ont effectivement une
apnée économique il ya tout lieu de
mettre d'utiliser tous les leviers de la
lune de l'agglo chose qui a été faite de
lundi soir et on peut que s'en féliciter
sur le département la dimension mendy
subventions d'état pour venir en jeudi
pour unia très rapidement je veux dire
en aide auprès de cinq ans maintenant il
ya aussi nécessité d'avoir une vraie
stratégie
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on compare
camair de proximité souvent passante
mobile accessibilité et ne vont que
l'ajout et la rue du général de gaulle
qui est souvent cité nous souhaitons
c'est d'avoir une réflexion qui nous
amène du col garde jusqu'au château cola
est un axe de garches moto qui nous
permettrait effectivement d'avoir une
réflexion aussi à la face dans la rue de
notre sur la rue jeanne et souvent vêtus
comme des garçons et bien sûr juste
jusqu'à la vérité car l aviation sans
oublier bien sûr la giraude ridan bière
est sans oublier bien sûr les commerces
de proximité que se trouve à carrefour
et qu'ils se trouvent je veux dire à la
clairière donc d'avoir une vue globale
est de pouvoir mettre en ordre de marche
toutes les possibilités pour accéder
tout à l'heure on l'évoqué à la fois
pour le piéton concurrent de plus nombre
d'entre nous le piéton le cycliste la
voiture d'avoir aussi des modalités de
stationnement qui permettent aussi
d'être attractif et pour ne pas
pénaliser le coeur de ville et d'avoir
aussi engager une réflexion sur la
titrisation
alors tout est ton ou tout voiture il ya
des mixtes ça marche très bien dans
certaines communes pour avoir quelques
expériences où effectivement il ya aussi
des temples piétonnisation dans la
semaine et ils payent même à la voir
dans la journée donc tout ça ça doit se
faire
bien sûr en concertation avec les
commerçants qui sont les premiers
concernés mais comme disait l'autre
outil les habitants pour le centre-ville
afin qu'ils habitent en ville de pousser
et des quartiers que hosni je lui dire
participer à la vie en tout cas que
pense que là s'il ya une chose positive
qui a karsenti c'est aussi leur
découverte proximité de ces petits
commerçants et tous les salles mais tout
à l'heure on en a fait état pour faire
preuve d'une très grande réactivité une
très grande timidité zone est à 4
minutes de temps de parole
j'arrête alors j'ai fait un petit point
sur l'assuré temps de parole david
l'outil vous en êtes à trois minutes 43
secondes trois minutes 29 secondes pour
véronique et matillon et quatre minutes
06 pour vous âgées schmidt alors nous
allons passer à notre deuxième
thématique elle concerne la démocratie
un local dans la ville vous voulez tous
développés est cette démocratie locale
comment développer la démocratie locale
à rambouillet je vais vous donner la
parole véronique matillon alors la
démocratie locale à à rambouillet
effectivement elle est déjà en place
elle est déjà en place grâce aux
conseillers de quartiers qui sont des
relais extrêmement important pour les
élus mais il faut effectivement
continuer et cette campagne m'a permis
en allant dans le quartier de voir à
quel point chaque habitant quartier est
impliqué et ça veut dire que ils sont en
capacité ce sont les personnes qui sont
les lieux
adapté à savoir ce qu'il convient de
faire dans leur quartier
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite absolument avoir une grande
partie de consultations avec les
habitants il est conseillé quartier bien
entendu seront là pour faire ce relais
mais aussi en ayant un élu chargé
justement de la démocratie consultative
au sein de l'équipe
et puis un élu qui soit plus consacré
aussi au niveau des quartiers c'est
l'information la démocratie aussi local
c'est aussi faire de l'information faire
de l'information régulièrement en toute
transparence
nous voyons bien à quel point est gelée
vu dans ma délégation et coll à quel
point il est important pour les citoyens
d'avoir toutes les explications et
lorsqu'il ya un projet ne peut pas avoir
lieu
il y à la compréhension du moment que on
peut leur apporter des explications
les raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
obligés de déplacer
et puis c'est aussi instaurer un budget
participatif par quartier qui permet à
chacun des quartiers d'avoir un projet
qu'ils montent et pour lequel ils auront
un budget alloué pour pouvoir le mettre
en réalisation david jutier vous voulez
notamment consulter les citoyens avant
tout nouveau grand projet c'est bien ça
oui c'est le c'est le minimum avant
d'engager des travaux ou des projets
impactant financièrement le moindre du
monde c'est de consulter à l'est le
premier première concernée vous posiez
la question tout à l'heure en
introduction de savoir pourquoi est ce
qu'il fallait en retenir pour moi pour
mon équipe
quoique lyon vient de donner
un exemple assez marco ou la cohérence
aussi et pour la confiance que les gens
peuvent avoir dans les propositions que
nous leur verdict matip deviennent par
les mots budget participatif calmette
met en place ses budgets partie les
allemands proposent des alors que média
déjà dans la majorité et nous a été
répondu alors que position totalement
démago et idéologies ont rien démocrate
donc si on sorti du chapeau je les
reproduis d'ailleurs une tour et
pourtant on n'a absolument pas été
défendu dans le mandat précédent
est-ce que je jauge mance et nous nous
sommes dit et ses budgets partie nous
avons réfléchi six ans de location
directorat donc évidemment placé
d'actifs à hauteur de 10% du budget
d'investissement de la ville d'un
million d'euros par ces chiffres
et puis j'aimais au crédit local
milliers de quartier nommé pour le maire
comme c'est le cas actuellement et qu'on
préfère encore vers maintenant que les
élus c'est morgane élections de manière
à ce que les habitants la liberté des
lignes électriques qui feront et puis
troisième étoile
à partir du moment où 900 personnes il
nous faudra nicipal ces quelques coups
mais engage véronique mathieu est ce que
vous voulez répondre à ce que vient de
dire david gauthier alors oui je vous
remercie
au sujet du budget participatif
monsieur jutier vous l'aviez proposait
en effet il
avait pas été retenu par éthique il est
important est la preuve
on est d'évoluer et de voir les choses
qui fonctionnent et qui sont
intéressantes à mettre en place
en revanche monsieur jutier
contrairement à ce que vous dites
cette proposition faisait déjà partie du
projet au premier tour puisqu'elle est
même écrite sur le projet que j'ai
proposé aux rambolitains et ça fait
partie de ce qui est écrit
donc voilà ça n'est pas un projet qui
sort du chapeau pour le deuxième tour ça
fait déjà un bon moment que nous
travaillons dessus
il devait sortir sur l'habillement alors
que vous n'avez pas mis en place et que
vous l'avez refusé pendant la mandature
c'est aussi la façon c'est aussi pour ça
que je ne suis pas monsieur robert je
suis une autre personne
une autre façon de voir les choses et
c'est aussi l'expérience de mandat au
niveau des écoles qui m'aide à
progresser
voilà je vais donner la parole à jésuite
sur sur la question la démocratie locale
c'était quand même ça vous apparaît
intéressant de doute c'était la première
fois qu'on va poser c'est comment avoir
vendu programme comment on élabore ce
programme et comment on va le gérer
comment on va le faire vivre plusieurs
choses la première c'est nous sans bien
sûr indispensable que de constituer des
conseils de quartier dotés de budgets
participatifs ça s'éteint avec un
montant qui s'approche à celui de david
douillet à savoir aux alentours de 10%
mais si tu nous sors aussi fondamental
c'est de couper court et de changer là
pour le coup de changer de façon de
faire à savoir non plus de nommer les
conseils de quartier mais d'organiser
des élections au sein des mêmes
quartiers tant qu'ils soient élus par
les habitants nous ce que nous
souhaitons aussi c'est une concertation
citoyenne c'est à dire a passionnément
on serait interpellée par mille citoyens
le sujet sur lequel on sera interpellé
serait automatiquement débattue au sein
du conseil municipal
mille pour que tu me comprenne bien ce à
peu près la taille d'un bureau de vote à
un gros bureaux de vote dirons nous
voilà ce qui permettrait là aussi de
pouvoir en toute transparence en aborder
ce sujet au sein du conseil municipal
mais uniquement si on voulait répondre
effectivement les j'entends monsieur j
thiais et monsieur j te dire que ils
souhaitent élire les conseillers de
quartier
les conseils de quartier actuel ont été
nommés et je ne vois pas la raison pour
laquelle nous serions dans l'obligation
de les remercier brutalement sous
prétexte que nous songeons le dispositif
ils ont été efficaces ils travaillent
ils sont connus les choses devront
peut-être évoluer plus tard mais en tous
les cas pour le moment nous avons déjà
beaucoup de conseillers de quartier qui
travaille énormément
voilà je ne pense pas que ce soit une
élection qui change beaucoup de choses
on va passer maintenant la troisième
thématique de ce débat l'environnement
la ville est un peu le symbole de la
ville à la campagne à une heure de paris
il ya énormément d espaces verts il ya
le parc du château il ya cette forêt de
rambouillet un espace boisé de 200 km²
quelles sont vos propositions concrètes
pour préserver ce cadre je vous donne la
parole
chiche mythe vous êtes un petit peu en
retard vous en êtes à 5 minutes et 19
secondes de temps de parole alors
concernant l'environnement il est bien
évident que nous rambouillet vie dans un
cadre privilégié nous sommes aux portes
de paris en bénéficier de la gare nous
avons nous avons à la frein puis à la
campagne un piia la ville ça c'est
indéniable nous ce que l'on propose
c'est d'avoir une approche là aussi un
peu plus à peine un petit peu plus un
pied ambitieuse je prendrais d'abord sur
la formalisation des énergies sur l'eau
l'électricité avec des investissements
qui seraient matière à faire des
économies d'avoir une réflexion chez
d'engager une réflexion par exemple sur
la sur les cantines sont entre autres
sur les cantines scolaires
s'appuyant bien sûr sur les producteurs
locaux là ça nous permettrait là
effectivement de pouvoir renforcer c'est
d'avoir aussi un regard différent sur la
façon de traverser la ville à la façon
de se déplacer dans la ville
tout à l'heure d'évoquer effectivement
le pôle gare mais d'avoir une réflexion
aussi sur les possibilités de mobilité à
pied sur les rendez vous à 12 cents
réserver aussi aux cyclistes
il ya un certain nombre d'autres sites
et de déplacement d'avoir un regard
voilà beaucoup plus large qui ne l'est
actuellement de faire cohabiter tous eu
tout ce monde et d'avoir effectivement
aussi la possibilité d'accéder à un
certain nombre de l'intérieur de la
mobilité d'un certain nombre de décès à
prayssas public comme on l'évoqué tout à
l'heure la gare mais aussi de pouvoir se
déplacer en centre-ville de peser dada
d'accéder aux écoles en toute sécurité
donc non pas d'avoir je veux dire une
une écologie punitive une et getti trois
restaurants mais d'avoir une écologie je
veux dire élargi concertée qui intègre
aussi une dynamique économique de nos
bénéficiant d'un environnement fabuleux
tu réfléchis aussi sur des thématiques
de bois d'avoir aussi une réflexion sur
avec les agriculteurs qui ont ils sont
tout autour de rambouillet je t'ai
l'ange évoqué les cuisines les la
cuisine centrale
les cantines scolaires de pouvoir
travailler avec eux pour organiser avec
eux des filières pour pouvoir
grosso modo les cantines scolaires ça
nous a pris quatre cent mille euros on
pourrait rajouter dans l'économie locale
donc ce sont toutes ces pistes qui nous
permettent d'avoir un regard légèrement
différente qu'il ne l'est actuellement
david itié vous en est à cinq minutes 56
secondes de temps de parole véronique
matillon sept minutes 11 secondes de
temps de parole sept minutes quarante et
une secondes pour vous à gilles schmitt
david ajouté vous proposer une vingtaine
de propositions dont la création d'un
plan climat air énergie territorial oui
c'est une obligation réglementaire que
de construire ce plan climat air énergie
territorial qui doit structurer le
territoire en matière d'écologie
d'environnement de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et ce plan climat
qu'avait été initiée avec l'agenda
l'agenda 21 il dort dans les cartons
tout simplement l'agglomération
embrouiller territoire ne respecte pas
son engagement de mise en place de ceux
de se planquer je le rappelle prévu par
la loi qui est une obligation et qui
permet de donner un cadre un cap
cohérent à notre action alors qu'elle
serait t'il ce cap
eh bien il ya eu une étude qui a été
faite un bilan carbone du territoire et
qui montre que sans surprise les deux
pôles les plus émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre sur notre territoire ce sont
les transports
tout d'abord et puis le chauffage des
bâtiments les habitations et le
tertiaire et donc je pense qu'il faut
avant tout nous attaquer à ces deux
postes d'émission pour préserver
l'ensemble de notre environnement quand
je disais tout à l'heure que notre
projet était un projet global qui sont
éternels localement c'est ça que ça veut
dire ça veut dire saisir des grands
enjeux de notre époque et l'enjeu
climatique et l'enjeu le plus fort de
notre époque et de voir ce que
localement puisque nous sommes des élus
locaux nous pouvons faire donc sur sur
la rénovation du bâti on a des leviers
qui n'ont jamais été activé localement
il est possible par exemple d'exonérer
partiellement ou totalement de taxes
foncières des personnes qui s'engagent
dans la rénovation du bâtiment
l'agglomération peut accompagner des
entreprises ou des commerçants ou des
artisans qui veulent se lancer dans la
rénovation énergétique
il ya énormément de choses à faire de ce
point de vue là avec le département au
travail et à la rénovation énergétique
des foyers les plus les plus modestes
est extrêmement extrêmement important
donc il ya énormément de choses que l'on
peut que l'on peut faire et puis il ya
un atout formidable qu'à notre notre
territoire c'est son environnement
forestier et agricole
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure je me suis
battu pour la préservation des terres
agricoles en périphérie de rambouillet
je pense que c'est très important
david utile aux mâles devoir donner la
parole à des reliques matillon
armin simplement très rapidement en
disant au delà de l'agriculture la forêt
dont nous disposons est un patrimoine et
une ressource et qu'il nous faut
accompagner la mise en place d'une
filière voie locale plutôt que de
laisser les arbres de rambouillet a
transporté jusque oit pour transformer
être transformé en chine ça aussi c'est
à la véronique matillon et dosettes à
vos fins au niveau de l'environnement et
bien entendu c'est une d attractivité de
notre ville de rambouillet beaucoup de
personnes nous disent c'est une ville à
la campagne
il nous faut absolument garder ce statut
et cet environnement particulièrement
agréable pour cela déjà il à la
municipalité actuelle il y avait y est
et je compte absolument préserver ses
terres agricoles au milieu de la ville
c'est une des particularités de la ville
de rambouillet quand on arrive pour
habiter à rambouillet on passe d'un
quartier à l'autre et on passe au milieu
de champs en fait et ça c'est très
important de le garder donc ça veut dire
de préserver toujours le plan local
d'urbanisme tel qu'il est c'est à dire
en préservant les terres agricoles au
sein de cette ville c'est aussi le fait
de continuer à accompagner ce que les
bailleurs sociaux ont déjà commencé sur
la ville de rambouillet et ont engagé
déjà financièrement se sont déjà
énormément engagé financièrement pour la
réhabilitation des logements sociaux au
niveau énergétique
c'est important parce que monsieur
jutier le souligner dans ces habitations
est bien les locataires doivent pouvoir
bénéficier d'un environnement qui
permette au niveau énergétique de faire
des économies
donc ça ce sont vraiment des choses
importantes j'ai schmitt laisse que vous
voulez réagir
vous avez un petit peu de retard vous en
est à sept minutes 41e seconde nous
avons environ une minute de temps de
retard oui en terme d'écologie a aussi
la nécessité en tout cas on a une belle
opportunité de réaménager nos quartiers
pendant cette campagne on a eu le temps
de lui dire de marché dans des toiles ou
vieira gones levier ou c'est on évoque
effectivement qu'il ya un certain nombre
de zones de deux champs agricoles au
sein de la commune en plus que s'en
féliciter
avec nos deux exploitants agricoles et
si en train de en termes de
développement durable
on peut aménager un peu plus de jardins
partagés par exemple dans ces quartiers
là qui sont sources aussi de partage qui
sont aussi une gestion de l'espace un
peu plus un peu plus un paquet de
l'actuelle mans on se doit alors
effectivement on engagé au travers les
bailleurs sociaux certain nombre
d'économies sur les énergies et on doit
les poursuit vincent le peu de féliciter
dans de poursuivre et accentuer et aider
soutenir mais aussi dans ces
quartiers-là l'écologie g mais
aujourd'hui râble proximité sursis
l'aménagement j schmidt
on est quasiment à égalité au niveau des
temps de parole je suis désolé véronique
patier on va passer maintenant aux
conclusions du débat la carte blanche et
vous aurez la parole dans l'ordre
inverse du premier tour de table en
début d'émission
vous avez deux minutes chacun environ on
va commencer par vous véronique matillon
justement quel est votre carte ballons
jeux je souhaite aborder le sujet de la
santé le sujet d'attenté était à aborder
en introduction de ce débat de
rambouillet effectivement est un acte
fondateur
il a prouvé durant cette crise qu'ovide
à quel point il a été important à quel
point il a été reconnu par la rs pour
tout ce qui est avec nous en classe nous
avons comme le disait le reportage des
départs de médecins qui ne sont pas
remplacés je suis bien placé pour le
savoir je suis infirmier sion et tous
les jours je sais à quel point des
actions des nouveaux rambolitains sont
en difficulté pour trouver des médecins
généralistes monsieur jutier propose
d'organiser une maison
de santé cervoni entre municipal de son
jeu vous expliquera tout à l'heure ce
que c'est voilà ce que j'étais venu
vision d'habitude faire venir des
professionnels de santé
durant la crise qu vide et je le savais
déjà
il ya une association des professionnels
de santé sur randy hillier qui est
extrêmement bien organisée et qui a su
mettre en place et c'est d'airé tous les
professionnels de santé pour pouvoir
travailler en lien avec l'hôpital
je pense que nous devons absolument nous
appuyer sur les professionnels en place
actuellement pour permettre cette trappe
attracting t elle
véronique matignon mais là vous mais
dépassé les 10 minutes de temps de
parole je vais passer la parole à jean
schmitt pour ça coûte et votre goût
d'avoir peu près la même carte blanche
dans son choix
je me permets dépendance est ce moment
de tirer un grand coup de chapeau
effectivement à tous les acteurs de
soins dits soit bien sûr hospitalier je
suis soit médecins de ville et tous ceux
qui ont contribué à la cette prise en
charge que vide aussi à tous les acteurs
de la ville qu'ils ont et qui ont
travaillé qui ouvrait sur des métiers
d'art dont on va peut parler d métier
d'aide-soignante brancardier infirmières
mais aussi des gens qui ont participé
dans la ville comme le service les
services communaux les entreprises de
collecte d'ordures ménagères là pour
tous ces gens là je tenais pendant cette
carte blanche allait savez pas ce que
c'est ils ont tenus ils ont fait le job
c'est des gens qui ont souvent été
convoi mais quand malheureusement qu'on
ne voyait plus qu'on n'entendait pas
beaucoup ils ont fait notre job il faut
sincèrement temps qui lui en tant que
citoyen et moi mais en tant que
hospitalier voilà j'ai je voulais les
saluer et souvent notre hôpital a
souvent été titillé ou critiquer là je
crois que si je peux me permettre cette
expression il ya pas photo ils ont
assuré ils ont fait les en fait le job
avec bien sûr mais quand il vous reste
une dizaine de secondes et mahias mais
c'est un c'est un travail remarquable
qu'il faut qu'il faut saluer en tout cas
je le fais en tant qu'élu je fais en
tant que citoyen et je fais aussi en
tant que collègue parce que j'ai des
collègues il abat sur le put alors
oublié
j'ai des amis de chimay je vais devoir
passer la parole à monsieur jti david
jutier votre carte blanche
vous avez environ une minute trente un
peu plus l'image du tout à fait d'accord
avec véronique matignon sur ce thème de
la santé il faut absolument s'appuyer
sur les sur les professionnels en place
qui sont regroupés dans une association
tout à fait compétente
la preuve en est c'est qu'elle ne s'est
pas associée comment dirais-je à
l'opération de communication de
dépistage du coc vide qui a été organisé
et on a vu au moins autant d'élus que
deux personnes se faire se faire tester
samedi matin au marché puisque c'étaient
des tests pcr qui n'ont plus grand
intérêt dans la période et ça me permet
de dire que mes chiens la gestion de
cette gestion de cette crise du que
vides localement a bien montré l'absence
de d'anticipation et l'absence
d'équipement localement pour anticiper
sur ces grandes crises je reviendrai pas
sur sur le problème des masques qui sont
arrivés alors que la crise était était
le gros de la crise en tout cas été
derrière nous et où surtout sur les
tests dont on a vu que de la même
manière il n'a pas pu être organisée à
temps à rambouillet alors que ça se fait
parfaitement dans d'autres dans deux
clips donc un centre municipal de santé
c'est une structure qui permet de très
attractive pour attirer de nouveaux
praticiens et qui ne rentre absolument
pas en compétition avec les
professionnels déjà déjà installés et
c'est extrêmement important pour une
politique de santé cohérente et de long
terme et j'aimerais terminer simplement
en disant seconde lorsqu'ils utilisent
grande gagnante ça a été
l'abstention est que chaque voix va
compter le 28 juin
merci merci merci merci monsieur juste
et merci à vous trois à savoir c'est
déjà la fin de cette émission merci à
vous trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
du second tour sur tv 68 et radio
sensations à des barres voix sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile et à réécouter sur radio
sensations
les électeurs en savent maintenant un
peu plus sur vos programmes je vous
donne la date du scrutin le dimanche 28
juin
en attendant la campagne se poursuit à
l'état sud d'un autre journal quotidien
chaque soir sur tv 78 à bientôt sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]
elle